KIPP Roy who's a fantastic Patriot in
the House of Representatives longtime
friend welcome to the program I want to
read you one sentence attributed to
Aristotle a radical change in the
character of the citizens
will be tantamount to a regime change
just as surely as a revolution in
political principles Aristotle's pretty
bright man I mean most of Western
civilizations built on Aristotle's
writings and thinkings and so forth and
so on
what do you think he'd be saying about
what's going on in the country today on
our border and with this Invasion that's
taking place well look great to be on
the show Mark and and it's a great quote
and you know another favorite quote of
mine is Sam Adams who said you don't
need a majority you need a tireless
minority being willing to set brush
fires of freedom and that is something
that has always stuck with me and you
and I you have lived that and I have
tried to live that right now we're
trying to expose and I think we're
successfully doing it to the American
people what's happening at our border
we've now been able to through the work
of Governor Abbott Governor DeSantis in
Florida and others helping highlight the
problem by frankly sending some of the
folks to New York City or DC or Martha's
Vineyard now people understand when the
mayor of New York is is calling this out
when the governor of Massachusetts is
declaring an emergency uh when you know
the and you got leaders in Los Angeles
who are talking about this crisis now
people are starting to wake up to what
we've been experiencing in Texas and
look this is what's really important
your listeners your viewers the people
who who know the truth they know what's
happening right this isn't new they know
about 304 000 Encounters in August they
know about 70 something thousand
Americans who die from fentanyl they
know about the little girls getting sold
into the sex trafficking trade and the
abuses the Dead migrants the 53 migrants
who died in a tractor trailer in San
Antonio Texas which I represent this is
the least Christian the least faithful
the least compassionate way that a
society could govern themselves in the
false name of compassion you just simply
detain
put an expedited removal or remain in
Mexico that's it that's the end of the
equation isn't that amazing to you even
with the corrupt media is as corrupt as
they are
they are the praetorian guard for this
Administration and the Democrat Party
I see some people talking about this in
a serious way about the reality of the
Border
but isn't it still amazing too how Joe
Biden is able to avoid direct criticism
you bring up the mayor of New York the
governor of New York these other people
you know don't leave the guts to say Joe
Biden your blood on your hands Joe Biden
because of your open border policies
tens of thousands of Americans are dying
uh we have children being sold into
slavery Joe Biden what are you going to
do about I notice when the questions
come up not that uh straightforward but
when they come up with the press
secretary she looks like she has a
constipated look on her face like she's
tired of this question she looks I don't
want to put up with it okay next next
the next net
isn't that amazing to you that we have a
president United States that gets away
with all this Mayhem and Anarchy and
inhumanity and he can't even be
questioned about it
yeah it's absurd I mean look I I will
say this on the positive right you know
when I was younger when you were younger
everybody said oh we get the truth we
get the truth and it's coming from
Walter Cronkite and from Tom Brokaw and
Peter Jennings no no we got filtered
truth quote unquote right uh we had Sam
Donaldson getting the truth sitting in
those press briefings with Ronald Reagan
now what we have is we're seeing the
everything's exposed right the emperor
has no clothes because now we have all
of these media options now yad's
difficulties goes filter through and
seek the truth through a thousand tweets
and all the different websites but now
we're seeing the truth because it's
unfolding before our very eyes so they
can't hide from it and the media doesn't
know what to do because they don't want
to be truthful and go call the president
out for it because he's advancing the
radical leftist agenda our job is to
expose it to the American people I hope
that all of the Republican president
presidential candidates will Elevate
this message I hope every elected
official across the country will Elevate
this message and for everybody who's
worried about how we go through this
process of funding government you know
so the reality is no matter what the
vast majority of your government because
our Founders gave us a republican form
of government across States and
localities not just the federal
government the vast majority of your
government continues there's 50 states
there's 3 000 municipalities there's 20
000 uh you know uh uh I think there's a
12 000 school districts and you know a
different governing bodies that are
actually going to continue operating no
matter what so the reality is we need to
do our job and say I'm not going to use
federal tax dollars or borrow more money
to fund a Secretary of Homeland Security
who's at war with the American people
and refusing to do his job hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else